here to break it all down in three
minutes is the host of the ben shapiro
show in daily wired.com editor-in-chief
my friend ben shapiro so there's a lot
on the president's plate and you I
wanted to talk to you about how do you
think they're managing that because in
some ways it does help by things I have
the United States seemed a little bit
unpredictable when you have all of these
different things happening around the
world I do think that you know for your
enemies you want to seem unpredictable
but for your allies you do want to seem
predictable your allies want to know
that you have their back and with regard
to Israel particularly the president has
been very consistent on that with regard
to the Korean situation that obviously
has has been a little bit more troubling
a the real question with regard to the
president meeting with with Kim jong-un
which may or may not happen now it
sounds like is will there actually be
preconditions what will those
preconditions be and what does the
president hope to get out of it if he
really believes that the Kim regime is
going to unilaterally disarm without the
United States pulling all of its troops
out of South Korea which is would be a
disastrous foreign policy mistake then I
think that he's sorely mistaken but
again this is a president who definitely
operates by his own rules I think that
sometimes that is a good thing is when
he bucks the conventional wisdom on
Jerusalem for example and sometimes not
so good is with the the tariff policy
for the speaking of tariffs I did want
to bring up one thing so Mario Draghi
who is the European Central Bank leader
had something to say about those tariffs
he said if you put tariffs against your
allies one wonders who the enemies are
and I noted this morning that you know
Brazil purchases a lot of coal from the
United States to make steel but then it
wants to export so it was not in the
carve out yesterday and they have now
already said well maybe we won't buy so
much coal from the United States so
there aren't these decisions aren't
without consequences that's right and I
think this is the big problem with some
of the issues on which the president
feels most passionate obviously he feels
passionately about trade and he believes
that America is being screwed and in
foreign trade deals but the evidence for
that is simply not there as a general
matter and this this particular
announcement seems you know off-the-cuff
it seemed like there wasn't even a
policy written to support it as of
yesterday and everybody is scrambling to
deal with that sort of unpredictability
is not good for markets it's certainly
not good for international trade it
could lead to the the
pression of the economy that's really
booming right now I mean the president
had a really good month in February
three hundred thirty thousand jobs added
it seemed like the best way to you know
cap that is with is with a move that is
is likely to put a damper on markets I
thought I maybe I asked you to talk
about Syria for a moment because you
know the president acted very decisively
early on in the administration and
showed Assad you know who's boss when it
comes to the redline on chemical weapons
and that now that whole situation is
just desperate especially for the
civilians including children do you
think that the president needs to
revisit and made me make a concrete
policy in that area well I mean
obviously we need something that more
resembles a policy and this isn't on
President Trump I mean this this thing
was a mess thanks to the Obama
administration he was handed a complete
mess a complete chaos and obviously he's
handled things well with regard to Isis
but if you if the humanitarian crisis in
Syria is have any concerns the
administration they're gonna need a
better policy than let Russia do what it
wants and every so often we'll have a
firefight with actual Russian militias
on the ground which is actually happen
so it's it's it nobody really seems to
know what's going on there and I'm not
sure there's a great solution but the
the administration isn't providing a
whole hell of a lot of guys well in
foreign policy or it's usually there's
never any great solutions usually
there's just better ones than your
alternatives ben shapiro make sure to
listen to his podcast everybody ben
shapiro you could find him on twitter
too at bench Brio thank you